bonsoir les lampions de la ferveur et de
la fête se sont éteints mais il serait
dommage de ne pas revenir sur cette nuit
du 8 décembre désormais la plus belle de
l'année à lyon
d'autant que ceux qui croient au ciel et
ceux qui n'y croient pas se sont
retrouvés pêle-mêle pour célébrer la
vierge et mozart pour prier ou déambuler
dans le froid et la liesse depuis 150
ans le 8 décembre lyon s'illuminent pour
célébrer la vierge et en 150 ans la fête
religieuse est devenue une fête tout
court
une fête de la rue avec spectacles feux
d'artifices et musique
et pour celui des sombres 1991 lyon
avait un maître de cérémonie presque
incontournable mais grandiose mozart
m
sur les quais de saône
un spectacle pyrotechnique de 35 minutes
retrace est en plusieurs tableaux les
grandes étapes de la vie de mozart au
siècle des lumières canon à images
fontaine lumineuse sur le fleuve et dim
11 enceintes diffusant les pièces les
plus connues du compositeur
hier le spectacle était partout pour le
plaisir des oreilles et des yeux
embrasant deux feux multicolores les
plus beaux monuments de la ville
dans les cafés dans les rues les
concerts ont donné un peu de chaleur à
cette nuit glaciale tandis que peu à peu
les bruits de la ville ont repris leurs
droits sur les bruits de la faune
et